If a person has severe arthritis of the ankle,
a doctor may recommend a surgical procedure
called ankle arthroplasty, or total ankle
replacement.
The ankle is the joint that connects the leg
and the foot.
The ankle joint includes the two lower leg
bones, called the tibia and the fibula, and
the ankle bone, called the talus.
The joint allows the foot to move up and down.
On the ends of the bones is a smooth gliding
covering called articular cartilage.
Sometimes the ankle can become damaged from
injury, or normal wear and tear, or other
diseases.
This can result in arthritis, which is painful
joint inflammation and stiffness.
Over time the articular cartilage can wear
away, causing the exposed bony surfaces to
rub together.
In addition, arthritis can lead to changes
in the shape of the bones of the ankle joint.
For example, boney projections, called bone
spurs, can develop.
The bone spurs, along with the damaged cartilage,
can make it hard to move the foot up and down.
As a result, it can be difficult to walk and
go up and down stairs.
Two types of arthritis that can affect the
ankle joint are osteoarthritis due to wear
and tear on the joint or injury, and rheumatoid
arthritis, one of several autoimmune disorders
that causes inflammation in the joint.
A surgical procedure called total ankle replacement
is done to replace a severely damaged ankle
joint.
The surgeon will make an incision on the front
of the damaged ankle to reveal the ankle joint.
Next, the ends of the tibia and the talus
will be removed.
A man made joint called an implant or a prosthesis
will be inserted into the ankle.
At the end of the procedure the incision will
be closed with stitches.
After ankle replacement the patient will be
able to move the ankle more fully and experience
less pain during activity.